hi everybody i'm ricky patel from Avaaz
this is my son Alon who's the best
nobody to be stuck at home for a few
months with and I just want to say how
excited I am about May the fourth
because it's the day we come together
from all across the planet to raise
eight billion dollars for the fight back
to fight to to get vaccines to get
treatments to make them fairly and
equally available to the most vulnerable
across the planet and and I'm excited
about that because I think this virus is
a teacher it has taught us how
vulnerable we are in our
interconnectedness I think may the
fourth is the beginning of another
lesson which is how powerful we are in
that interconnectedness how we can come
together from every part of this planet
and and fight back and and make magic
together and we've got a petition of
over 1 million people from across the
world sign on of Oz calling on our
governments calling on all of us let's
do it let's come together one world one
people one tribe let's do it for love
let's do it for everything we love
including this one
you